MATT WARD: So I guess
we can get started.
My name's Matt Ward,
and this is my
friend, Steven Robertson.
And today we're going to tell
you a little bit about how
we're changing the way we stream
videos at YouTube.
We're going to talk about
adaptive streaming.
And as you know, we'll
be talking about
the internet today.
This is a great picture that
my friends over at
collegehumor.com put together.
You can go check it out if you
don't know any of these memes.
A lot of them are YouTube
memes, which is why I'm
showing this off.
And we're actually going to go
and talk about the birthplace
from our perspective.
This is not the artist-- once
the artist uploads it, this is
kind of where everything
starts for us.
And that's in our Google
data centers.
We're making some big changes
about how we're processing
these videos that we're
going to go into.
And then the next part of these
video's life cycle, if
you will, is traveling
through these pipes.
And these are kind of the first
pipes that these videos
go through as they leave our
data centers and head towards
your computer.
It is one of the first possible
places that we can
see congestion.
And there's a lot of congestion
out there on the
internet today.
No, I have to click that
and this slide.
And this is really kind of
what we're doing to the
internet today with all of the
data that we're putting
through it.
We're really just doing this.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
MATT WARD: Don't worry,
it'll start.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE IN VIDEO]
MATT WARD: We're pushing as much
data as possible through
these pipes right now.
And it's kind of getting
crowded in there.
So when it gets crowded
like that, this is
what our users see.
They get a buffer spinner.
Your network gets congested,
and you're not able to pull
data down as quickly
as you were before,
and so, buffer spinner.
So today we're going to talk
about a four-year project at
YouTube to change the
way that we actually
stream videos to users.
We're going to talk about
two projects.
The first project
is called Zeri.
It's something Adobe introduced
to us, a new API,
specifically, that Adobe
introduced to us back in 2009.
It took us a couple of years
to get a working prototype,
and another year to actually
ship it to all of our users.
And then we started really
focusing on HTML5, and we're
going to end today talking about
how we're doing the same
kind of thing in HTML5.
So let's kind of get started.
We actually refer to this
project as Sliced Bread
internally.
We talk about it as chunked
video playback.
The best thing since
sliced bread.
And that's because before for
these APIs, we were delivering
video in giant loaves
of bread like this.
There was nothing between
the internet
and the actual plug-in.
Here, I'm going to
give you a couple
flash examples to start.
And we really just used to send
the video right into the
net stream, and the
video would play.
That was it.
There wasn't any more
complication to it.
And then we introduced the Zeri
API, and now we sit right
in between the internet and
the plug-in, and we really
have control over how
quickly the data is
flowing through it.
And we chunk everything.
And we'll go into why that
happens in a minute.
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT WARD: Exactly.
There's four reasons why.
We will go into each of them
in more details, but let's
start talking about
efficiency.
And like I said, chunking.
So the first piece of the
pipeline that we built was
taking the video and requesting
it in ranges.
So rather than just requesting
the whole entire video in one
big request, kind of like
putting data on as it comes
along, what we did is we said,
OK, give me two megabytes.
And then I'll put that on.
Give me another two megabytes,
and then I'll put that on.
And what this did was it
actually reduced our
over send by 5%.
This is a really big
savings for us and
great for the internet.
We actually were making more
space on the internet for
other people to send bytes
through, because we made this
improvement here.
So, let's go into another
advantage that this gave us,
which is because we were doing
this chunked request thing,
what's happening is when we go
and seek around the video, we
will try and align your chunk
request again so that the
browser can actually handle
a layer of caching for us.
So if we seek back to, say, zero
seconds, and you're all
at the end of the video, and the
browser had that first two
megabytes of the video in cache,
we can get access to
that really quickly.
And that's kind of the first
layer of cache that we see.
And the next layer is
actually a little
bit more in our control.
So the browser cache, we don't
have any control over the
eviction that's going
on there.
We can't actually say,
do you have this two
megabyte chunk in memory?
The browser hasn't given us an
API for that, and we don't see
one coming anytime soon.
So we introduce this
next layer of cache
that's really in memory.
And that's really what you're
seeing when you see a buffer
bar on our video.
That's the amount of data that
we're actually holding in
memory inside of the
Flash plug-in.
So once the data flows out of
our in memory holdings, we
kind of send it up to this net
stream object in Flash.
And that's where the decoder
kind of lives.
And once we've passed the bytes
in there, we really
don't have any control over it
anymore, and the only thing we
can do is say stop.
So, let's talk a little bit more
about this buffer bar.
So this is our great
seek bar here.
And what we used to do is to try
and prevent all that over
send we talked about
a little earlier.
So we used to actually have
logic in our servers that
trickled the bytes down.
Believe it or not, this
logic wasn't perfect.
I know it's shocking.
But now that we are looking at
how many bytes the client is
actually receiving, and we
have this really accurate
measurement of how many bytes
are arriving on the client,
we're able to effectively
manage how much
read ahead we have.
And today we kind of cap
that around 40 seconds.
And that's what we found
was a good value.
When you made that value larger,
you crash a lot of
Flash plug-ins.
Trust me.
So the next thing here that
I've pointed out that we
changed was we had this other
really advanced logic in our
servers to handle a certain
kind of seeking.
So when we talk about seeking
there's two kinds of seeking.
The first kind of seeking
is what we
call in buffer seeking.
And that kind of looks
like this.
You seek to an area that you
kind of have already
downloaded and you have in
memory in the browser.
And these we're able to handle
by feeding the bytes we kind
of already have in memory
right in there.
Now, what happens when you seek
to this region, which we
don't really know
anything about?
Right?
In the past, those in buffer
seeks were really simple,
because the plug-in just
handled them for you.
You didn't have to think
about it at all.
But when you did this, the
plug-in would say, I don't
know anything about that.
What can you do for me?
And we would re-request the
whole entire stream again by
appending a start parameter to
the actual URL, and say, hey,
I seek to a minute into the
video, but I'd only downloaded
30 seconds, right, so I don't
know about what's going on
that minute.
So really you would say, start
at 60 seconds and give me a
video stream from there.
And the servers would stitch
together a new video for us.
And we changed that, and now we
do all of that logic on the
client side.
And it's made our servers a
lot dumber, if you will.
But our clients are really,
really smart.
And it also let us play some
really neat tricks on the
client that we'll talk
about later.
So to do client side seeking
like this, we have to gain a
really, really clear
understanding of what the
container is.
So I'm going to give a little
background on what videos
actually look like.
And I'm going to make a little
analogy for you.
Videos are like tacos.
They look exactly like this.
So what do I mean?
OK.
So, the meat of this video,
the stuff that we really,
really care about is
the underlying
video and audio codecs.
Here I give a few examples of
that on the left over here.
And then, the container is this
kind of stuff that wraps
around the outside.
It kind of tells you something
about what's inside.
It's what keeps the whole video
together, if you will.
It brings all of these
individual samples that we've
encoded together into this one
big glorious hunk of video.
So what we did in our project
initially that we did in Flash
was answer this question of how
do we know a byte offset
for a time that the
user requests?
And we kind of built this really
common interface for
the whole entire thing.
You know FLV, we have this
time to byte map.
MP4s have these things
called moov atoms.
Sidx, kind of the same story.
HLS and DASH each
have a manifest.
The manifest says, oh, well
here's five second chunk, five
second chunk, five second chunk,
and that's kind of the
granularity you get there.
So we built a kind of common
interface to that from time to
byte that our application can
query into to find out this
answer that's so important
for seeking.
The next part was for the
samples that we actually hold
onto, we'll talk about this in
a second, but we actually
sometimes switch the codec that
we're using in the middle
of playback.
We're doing this a little less
and less today, and I'll talk
about that later.
But let's first talk
about what a video
really looks like.
And it looks a lot more
like this than a taco.
So the videos kind of start
with this thing that
initializes the decoder.
You kind of tell the decoder,
this is the key frame I'm
about to feed you.
This is what--
the data you're about to see
is going to look like this.
That's what we start
by saying.
And then videos have key frames
and progressive frames
and this simple example here
uses H264 without any fancy B
frames or anything that you
guys might know about.
And some basic AAC audio.
That's a lot of what we've been
streaming these days.
So let's go into how
we do adaptation.
One of the big things that we're
able to do now is switch
between streams.
So here we have two streams.
A and B. And we detect
that there's a
change in the network.
Right?
And what we want to do is
this, make a switch.
So when we make a switch, that
has to happen at a key frame,
because the decoder will not
understand if you switch at a
progressive frame here.
How do I make this transfer from
my current data to some--
each of the progressive frames
kind of build on key frames.
So you must feed a
key frame first.
And that's the logic that we
also had to be very careful to
take care of.
So once we kind of had this
understanding of all this
stuff, and really understand how
to glue videos together on
the fly in our clients, we
introduced this simple
splicing mechanism.
Now, this is going to look
crazy, but this is what our
application got to
at this point.
We were building and tearing
down all of these things that
parse and handle different media
containers, and cache
each of those individual files
that you're pulling
separately.
And then we had this
splicing thing that
switched back and forth.
And this API was really
interesting and really fun to
work with, but Steve's going to
talk about its implication
of this later in HTML5, so you
guys don't have to deal with
any of this stuff anymore.
So the next part, once we
have all this stuff, how
do we launch it?
Well, like I said, this took
us four years from start to
finish, more or less.
And even once we finished, all
of the stuff that you saw so
far, we had all of it
like code complete.
We spent months finding bugs,
and launching experiments, and
trying to figure out where
are all the problems.
So let's talk about a couple
of those problems here.
The first problem, remember how
I had those nice pretty
lineups between all of videos?
That's not really what
our videos look like.
They look a lot more
like this.
So if you're going to switch
between stream A and stream B
here, what's going to happen
is you're going to have to
switch at that key frame.
Are you going to switch in the
middle of that progressive
frame on the top one?
Or are you going to drop
that progressive frame?
So what would happen is you
would either get black
flashes, or you'd
go back in time.
Some people don't notice this,
because it's very, very quick.
But this was happening.
Well, I had a worse problem.
People are more sensitive
about audio.
Audio--
if you're doing this in audio,
you're making pops and
glitches is in people's ears.
This is bad.
So for a while, actually, we
were paying the price of the
occasional pop and glitch in
people's ears, for the cost of
less re-buffers and smoother
play backs.
We tried to limit how many
switches we would do during a
play back to minimize the
number of these kind of
problems that users would see.
But what we're doing today
is we're making our
videos look like this.
We're re-transcoding everything
inside of YouTube
to really improve
the experience.
We want all the key frames
lined up so that when we
switch streams, you don't
even notice any
black frames or anything.
The audio, for all of our
qualities now, the
audio is the same.
When we're playing an auto
adapted playback.
We hold the same exact audio
stream at CD quality through
the whole entire thing.
It's great.
I mean, you know how everyone
always used to switch up, to
like try and get that better
audio quality?
Well, now we hold the same one
for almost all of them.
This also enabled a bunch of
other neat things, but Steve
might talk about those later.
The other major problem that
we had was our caches.
So at YouTube, we have a
bunch of caches, where
we store our videos.
This is shocking.
Basically, this is what they
used to look like.
Formats A, B and C, for
a video, were all
on different machines.
So when we wanted to pull one
of these videos, we had to
open a new connection to a new
machine, and say, hey, how
quickly can you get me
those video bytes?
And the actual rate at which
you can get them from these
two different machines might
vary, because of, like I said
before, varying network
conditions, right?
This is all about understanding
what the network
is like between you and
the server you're
pulling videos from.
When you start changing that
in the middle of your
adaptation, it gets really,
really complicated.
So we did this.
We moved everything
on to one machine.
And that took months.
We had to redesign our caches
from the ground up to make
this happen.
It was a very, very large
project, as you
could probably imagine.
The last problem, latency.
So anyone want to guess where we
launched adaptive streaming
and Flash in this?
We'll talk about that in a
minute, but right in the
middle here, you'll see the blue
line is Flash, red line
is HTML5, and all of a
sudden, HTML5 is a
lot faster than Flash.
I'm going to hand it over to
Steve to tell you about why
we're switching to HTML5 and
why this is the case.
And he'll talk about HTML5.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Thanks Matt.
So when we started doing
application level streaming, a
new security mechanism
kicked in.
That security mechanism is
a cross origin request
restriction.
When you try and place a request
to a new domain,
because all of our videos are
stored on separate machines,
that request needs a security
check first.
And that security check is
implemented in Flash by making
an initial request to a
policy file located at
the document root.
That initial request has to
complete before the next
request cam start.
In HTML5, that information is
actually embedded straight
into the HTTP request and
response, and the browser is
responsible for dropping
response.
It offers the same level
of security, but
no extra round trip.
And that tiny little XML file
makes the difference between
HTML5 being faster.
So this change actually has a
lot of fortuitous timing,
because for the first time,
we're also able to append
media directly to the video
element from an application
control in HTML5.
The media source extensions are
a new specification in the
W3, just won't work in draft.
And they basically do the same
thing that Zeri did.
They offer an application and
opportunity to append a data
straight to a media element.
And in fact, in the first draft,
they basically look
exactly like Zeri.
And we tried this out, and we
realized that it wouldn't
actually work.
Well, it would work on desktop
Chrome, but we needed this to
be everywhere.
We needed this to be on phones,
we needed this to be
on TVs, and the API
just was not as
portable as the web required.
And understanding that takes us
to one of the core axioms
of engineering work
at YouTube.
Which is that playing
videos is hard.
Surprisingly hard.
But it's a little easier to
understand given the history
of video codec development.
This is just one facet of it.
But the codecs themselves are
optimized for a tremendous
number of conditions and each
one has separate trade offs.
But they're all gunning
for lower bit
rate, or higher fidelity.
And none of the things that
they're optimized are
simplicity.
In fact, the codec target for
most next generation codecs,
whatever that generation is, is
like, oh, we'll only double
or triple the complexity.
And we at YouTube are thrilled
about this, because it does
cut down on the most important
expenses, and lets us access a
lot more content and distribute
it more widely.
But when you tell a bunch of
very smart scientists and
engineers to make something more
complicated over the span
of 40 years, they succeed.
So Adobe dealt with this
originally in the Flash player
by basically drawing a map.
By codifying exactly what their
platform would do under
all of these circumstances.
And that allowed developers to
build applications for the
first time that would be able
to do complicated mechanics,
like the things that we do
in the YouTube player.
It was a tremendous
boom for the web.
It allowed a lot of video
applications and videos, of
course, really fundamental to
all kinds of experiences.
And that was a fantastic move.
But it was a trade off,
because when you build
applications with these
implementation details in
mind, they become brittle.
They are hard to port.
They're hard to maintain.
And the Flash plug-in itself
has a lot of portability
limitations due to restrictions
from those kind
of implementation agreements.
By contrast, the W3 expects and
mandates that their specs
are interoperable, that
you can get multiple
implementations going.
And the append bytes model
didn't really fit with that.
So, with the Chrome media team,
we worked out a system
that was a little bit richer,
had more of an intermediate
layer, so that you could
hide those interfaces.
And so the media source spec
became much more effective at
doing that.
The core feature of this
is the source buffer.
The source buffer is
an abstraction.
It's mostly a timeline.
And once you create a source
buffer object, you can just
append media to it, after
you've downloaded it by
whatever means.
And as you continue to append,
to a certain point, the media
is retained on the timeline.
That's a lot like appending
media to a queue
in the normal situation.
So to understand more about
why this is so important,
let's talk about an
Adaptive Upswitch.
The adaptive algorithm has a
single goal, which is to put
the best video quality
in front of
the user at all times.
And that means that if you're
watching a video, and you
suddenly detect that you have
additional bandwidth, the
player is going to start
downloading new video, not at
the end of the queue, but as
soon as it can, for the next
adaptive checkpoint.
And normally what you would
expect is you just drop that
new media in there, and it will
swap out for the media
that is playing at 10 seconds
on this diagram.
But underneath, the decoder
might have actually started
pulling data far ahead.
On Chrome, for instance, this
is like two or three frames,
which is great.
On a lot of TVs, it could be
10 seconds read ahead.
And the platform needs to find
a way to communicate this
effectively to the client if
you were using it in a pen
bite style API, where you're
doing all this manual
management.
On the other hand, the source
buffer abstraction is capable
of keeping track of
all this for you.
So all you do is drop in the
media, and source buffer takes
care of knowing when to splice,
and retaining the
existing information so that
the decoder is pulling from
exactly the right samples.
And then once that process is
done, it'll swap in exactly
what you told it to, so that way
the representation in the
browser is exactly what the
application expects it to.
So that's how we're doing
adaptive streaming in both
HTML5 and Flash.
A more interesting question
is what's in it for you?
Why is this beneficial
for our users?
And on a familiar theme,
the most important
reason for us is speed.
A lot of the existing adaptive
schemes may be simpler for
applications to implement,
but they have
a significant penalty.
For example, one streaming
protocol, in order to do this
adaptation, requires multiple
separate requests before it
can get started.
Some these requests are
megabytes of things that
aren't movies.
And that cost has to
be paid up front.
The media source solution allows
us to embed a lot of
that logic, and cuts down the
number of requests so that we
can start making media fetches
at the top of the page,
because we can coordinate that
with our application.
Another important feature
is experiments.
YouTube's constantly running
experiments.
At any given time, you can
expect hundreds of experiments
are going on.
And because we see billions of
playbacks a day, these get
data and are collected and
processed very quickly.
And platform makers, browser
manufacturers, just don't have
that instrumentation.
They would have to build a
YouTube in order to collect
that much data.
So we can tune our algorithms
a lot faster, release new
ones, and adapt to the changing
network conditions
and geographic regions.
Another thing we find out from
all this experimentation is
that there's a lot of region
specific differences in what
people like to see.
For instance, in the United
States, people would rather
watch a buffer spinner than see
their video adapt down to
the very lowest qualities.
But in other parts of
the world, people
would prefer the 144p.
They're like, don't even
give me the 360P.
I want this to start quickly.
So you have to build these
differences in a way that you
can see the responsiveness, and
that requires this kind of
online continuous tuning
and experimentation.
Another surprising thing we
learned from this process is
that software has bugs.
Some bugs are more surprising
than others.
For instance, if a popular
mobile handset manufacturer
releases a software update that
opens TCP connections and
doesn't close them,
you get something
that looks like this.
A globally distributed denial
of service attack on your
servers that lasts for months.
And there's basically nothing
you can do to avoid this
situation except sit
and wait and hope
they release an update.
That means that we have to
make the choice between
degrading service for all users,
or cutting off a large
fraction of users.
And we never want to
make that choice.
With application level
streaming, we can deliver a
fix or a work around in hours,
instead of months.
And finally, there
are a lot of new
features that this unlocks.
One that's great for our users
is pre-loading the video, so
we can make sure that videos on
the page start even faster.
By downloading exactly how much
video we need without
going over.
We couldn't enable this on a
global basis, because some
browsers will actually start
downloading the whole video.
So having this application level
control gives us the
assurance that we're doing the
right thing by the user.
I'm really excited about global
load balancing, but
that is an internal feature,
and the only effective
response that you'll see is that
things will be much more
stable over time.
You won't encounter these
hiccups where your video
connection suddenly gets slow
because one link is congested.
So being able to see this, as
we mentioned, Flash, it is
live at 100 percent.
HTML5, the media source APIs are
implemented in Chrome, and
we look forward to rolling
those out.
You can join the HTML5
experiment to see how things
work today.
Or just stay put, and in the
next couple of months, you'll
see this HTML5 experience
shipping natively on Chrome
and then on any other browsers
that pick up this API.
And we're also--
a lot of our TV and console
applications are built on web
technologies.
So this same player will appear
there, and handsets
will use the same streaming
strategies.
So thank you for watching both
this presentation and YouTube.
And if you all have any
questions, we'd
love to hear them.
[AUDIENCE CLAPS]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What is it for us like
developers that need to give
our users content?
I mean, are you making any of
these available for us to use
on our own websites instead
of YouTube?
STEVEN ROBERTSON: The media
source extensions?
The media source is
a new web API.
So anybody can use it.
But what we expect to happen,
and have seen some activity
around, is that content
distribution networks will
actually be doing the same kind
of experimentation and
produce algorithms that are
tuned for their networks.
So what they'll expose to users
is a simple player, a
JavaScript thing.
AUDIENCE: Mmm hmm.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: You just
drop it in, and that
JavaScript takes care of all
of the adaptive logic.
But of course, being a web
technology, if you want to get
in there and actually implement
your own stuff, more
power to you.
You definitely can.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATT WARD: Of course, you're
also welcome to use our video
player, which will just
do this all for free.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Great presentation, thanks.
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering, why is
there no always play in HD
option on YouTube?
There's one that is play in HD
when you're in full screen,
but what happens all the time
when I watch videos, I launch
the video, put it in full
screen, and I've got like the
15 or 20 first seconds
not in HD.
And it's like, OK.
I would always use the
HD option if it was
there, but it's not.
Is there a reason for that?
MATT WARD: So I think part of
what you're asking here is--
is your question more why am I
not getting HD right away when
I go full screen
or is it more--
AUDIENCE: So that I understood,
thanks to the
presentation, it's why you do
not let users actually always
have HD all the time
if they want to.
MATT WARD: So you remember
how the pipes are
getting really clogged?
So if we did that the pipes
would be even more clogged and
nobody would be able
to get through.
So we're doing the best thing
here for a number of reasons.
For that reason we're
conservative about how we're
using bandwidth on
the internet.
In addition, we're never
actually going to send you a
720P video into a little
360P screen.
This actually puts a lot more
strain on your CPU and your
local processing, and will drain
your battery faster.
We're thinking about things like
that and trying to pick
the right quality for the size
screen that you have, as well
as account for certain network
conditions that
you might be seeing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MATT WARD: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a question about rate
estimation, because in a
mobile device your radio
changes very fast.
How do you guys do that, and
how fast can you do it?
STEVEN ROBERTSON: Some of the
more interesting strategies
for rate estimation on mobile
devices involve packet pacing
to actually look at the
interarrival time.
WebRTC uses this strategy.
And TCP doesn't have the-- at
the web level, TCP doesn't
have the exposure to
measure those APIs.
So one strategy we're exploring
is to perform some
client server cooperation on TCP
window clamping to get an
estimate of this.
But the short answer is it's a
hard problem, and we're still
looking in to how to solve it.
It's definitely a challenge.
It comes down to being more
conservative on mobile.
When you detect that you're on
a mobile network, there's a
little bit more conservativeness
as just our
fallback until a better
solution is presented.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: On iOS, certainly, and
also on Chrome on Android,
at least on recent versions of
Android, you live stream using
HLS, which is built into mobile
Safari, and I assume
it's also built into
Chrome on Android.
So is that application level
streaming or is that system
level streaming?
MATT WARD: That's system
level streaming.
That's actually exactly
what we we're talking
about on that slide.
That was a picture
of how HLS works.
So basically, on these devices
today, we don't have access to
the APIs that we talked
about in the second
half of this talk.
Those APIs don't exist.
And for that reason today we are
still doing live streaming
via HLS, because we really want
to hit all of the devices
on the market.
We really want you to have live
streaming on your iPad
and your iPhone and
your Android.
So that's really why we're
doing HLS today on those
devices, and that's
why you see that.
AUDIENCE: So you're going
to switch over or
what is the road map?
MATT WARD: Yeah.
When the API becomes available
on all these devices, we would
ideally like to see our
applications having full
control over streaming
during--
we want that application level
control of streaming live.
We are fully capable of doing
it today on the desktop, but
again, for portability reasons,
we're still using HLS.
AUDIENCE: So on iOS it would be
implemented in your Chrome
implementation somehow?
MATT WARD: Yeah.
I mean Chrome, we hope, is
finishing bringing media
source to our mobile Chrome
very shortly, is my
understanding.
I don't work on the Chrome team,
so I can't actually say
what the timeline of that is,
but yeah, it's coming.
AUDIENCE: I would like to follow
up on the HD question.
On my mobile device, I totally
get I don't want my battery to
run down, I don't things
to get hot.
But, say on the pixel, for
example, when I've got my LTE
connection with 20 plus megabit
download speeds, and
I've got a video that
I want to--
I want to see the quality.
I'm that kind of person.
So I prefer to wait.
But it's coming instantly.
What protocols are in place that
makes it go to a lower
quality setting whenever I've
got plenty bandwidth and
plenty CPU processing power?
MATT WARD: One thing you might
actually have is a lot of
bandwidth to a lot
of the network.
So you might have a great, great
connection to wherever
you're doing your
speed test to.
You might not actually have
a great connection to our
servers, so we might not
actually have a 20 megabit
connection to your device
on an LTE network.
So the number that we're
actually seeing is the one
that is informing our stream
selection logic.
So from our perspective, and
from a lot of our experiments,
we value smooth play backs
and fast play backs.
We're talking, actually,
there's a lot of heated
discussion about this exact
thing internally right now.
And we're trying to figure out
exactly how we can give more
fine grain quality controls for
people like you that want
really to crank it
up if I can.
And today, our best answer to
that is, go full screen.
And these algorithms are
going to do their best.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
And I will ask you right now.
I request that there be an
option for HD playback, no
matter what is going on.
MATT WARD: I will accept
your request.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
MATT WARD: Well, thank you
guys very much for coming
today, and enjoy the rest of
the activities this week.
[AUDIENCE CLAPS]